[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey there little man
[Music]
i was a good friend of your father's
i served with him
in that hanoi pit of hell
for over five years
had it been me who died like your dad
died a bunch
i would be talking
well i wouldn't be i would be dead like
your dad
but your dad would be talking to my son
right now jimmy
about nutrition
jimmy has hobbled legs
and i don't know if he's mine i don't
like him
but you know he's a boy
still
so anyway
your dad told me to bring you something
special
and i want to keep my word
what i got is called the belt bar
it was first purchased by your dad
in a little general store by a company
called bilpar
the first company to make built bars
your father always liked to have an
extra one on him and it was in his
pocket when he was shot down over
hannahway
he knew if the viet kong
ever saw this delicious and nutritious
bill bar
that'd be confiscated taken away
he'd be damned if any charlies were
gonna put their greasy hands on his
boy's birthright so he hid it in the one
place he knew he could hide something
his ass
five long years
he kept this bar in his ass
then he died a dysentery gave the bar to
me
and i hid this tasty hunk of wonder up
my ass
for two years
then after seven years
i was sent home to my family
and now little man
oh
here
take it
take my asses build bar
oh no
[Music]
dot com
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
hmm
and that sip is just right
thank you johnny really yeah it's just
right how many times like the baby bear
yeah with the baby bear which really um
goldilocks was a felon she was it wasn't
her house no that wasn't her he had no
business being there she absolutely
should have been mauled yeah squatters
rights i'm sorry is that it
yeah it was pacific heights goldilocks
white girls think they could do whatever
they want yeah that's true
if you joke into the woods today you're
gonna hear me too uh i don't know why uh
she swallowed that fly that's not
goldilocks does it
i don't think so you shouldn't die from
swallowing a fly unless it's in zambia
and then you know it's really more of
that i don't know why a family wasn't
home and there was porridge and it was
all various temperatures yes that makes
sense i also don't understand why being
a minimalist they had to have
beds of different softness and different
chairs like come on just make this make
it uniform bears
picking a part of children what is it
with and then they have the four pigs
three pigs three and the wolf oh there
was four what did you expect well yeah
but would you expect
yeah well
that's the official story right yeah
right
shallow grave
uh orthopedic
yeah
it's swine flu
oh that's right i'm incredible
why would you build a house out of straw
that's my point if you see your brother
building a house out of bricks
you should have known better and uh
puffy should be dead what was the third
house there was straw
wood sticks and brick
sticks yeah it actually would be a lot
harder to build a house out of straw
than bricks well it was it would be you
have to put a lot of effort into
building a crappy house it was a native
pig just going back we're off the beam
here okay look guys glad to be with you
look it is a live show monday through
thursday if you're still here 10 a.m
eastern if we're not on youtube run
rumble we will let you know when we have
to miss a day if we're on location
shooting like a change of my mind or a
super video don't be worried about my my
nasal voice right now it's not the
omicron southern wind and the pollen and
the bum piss from austin
[Applause]
so 10 a.m eastern
it'll be on the rumble and we have a lot
to talk about today i don't know if you
know this inflation is really bad no
yeah at a 40-year high
and a big part of that of course is the
drug companies also want to privatize
profit socialize losses we're going to
get into merck and pfizer a little bit
and how they've been buying off
politicians also some republicans that
i'm not necessarily thrilled with also
um joy reid is a person
still yeah i didn't know this i thought
she was fired
i think yeah but she still is yeah and
technically really she's an unemployed
person oh i thought but i can never tell
if it's a joyride clip or a clip of
someone else because
like i don't was she stung by a bee is
it is it a hairdo change is it a weave i
never she never looks the same twice it
does not yes that's true but they're
proposing now attacks on you the unvex i
know you're saying that'll never happen
in america well guess what in my home
country of canada uh it's happening yeah
in the province of quebec and it's
happening in other countries keep in
mind the only fail-safe that you have
here in the united states
is
that there is still some semblance of a
conservative wing when people say ah
both sides no no one side wants you to
be forced into lockdown one side wants
the kind of concentration camps that
they have sorry quarantine camps in
australia one side wants you to have to
pay an additional tax for not taking an
experimental mrna injection one side
wants all of these things doesn't mean
that you have to have an r next to your
name but you are precluded from
put it this way voting for anybody who
could be seen at a cocktail party with
joyride now
and let me ask you this what do you say
who do you think is most responsible for
the inflation i want you to comment
below that's the best thing like we've
said for the algorithm for youtube
elizabeth warren blames kroger ah yeah
big kroger yeah big kroger uh big piggly
wiggly yeah big deal i think it has a
little more to do with printing money uh
which i've never understood if you can
just print money why tax at all
and of course uh blackrock is this huge
firm that you know they're buying up all
the houses and uh you know just
nothing's working but the good thing is
there's there's no good thing so before
we uh continue oh i forgot there's still
the promo code oh yeah yeah 20 off if
you join mug club no advertising revenue
here on the youtube that's for sure none
that stings my fault so twenty dollars
off you enter into lwc returns but
before we get to anything else
oh god uh i totes forgot to put my club
my plugs i thought they were just like
well you you haven't introduced us yet
we've cheryl day how are you i'm i'm you
know what i want a genuine how are you
steven
gerald a how are you now that you've had
your third glass of wine by 1080.
fantastic yeah good he had a box of
franzia just waiting oh good lord i may
be an alcoholic but i have standards
chased it down with a nice yellow tail
it was damn you both some cold duck well
barefoot doesn't count that's brotagan's
favorite then we have the uh of course
you know him you love him he has dates
coming up uh you can follow him on the
twitter at landow dave to see more about
these dates uh reading california where
they're trying to make it so that you
can't go see him oops
and then sacramento i believe dave
landau how are you ahoy i'm good i've
never been better ever in life wow
that's fantastic yeah i don't believe
you but i'm not i'm completely lying
yeah well every day is a gift you know
what you were here for run through joy
reid's rubbing off on you oh she's a
doll
big kroger taking all our money
i knew it was i knew it was
i knew it was the rothschilds and vons
yeah
just
before any of this so i'm sorry to do
this but uh this is going around um
lizzo just celebrated her recent uh
oh i'm sorry it's celebrated her recent
weight gain
really cool
because that's a thing now
with this brave and beautiful video
make a video
[Music]
[Music]
i actually appreciate that she was
forthcoming about being hog-tied uh
there's by the way there's no you hear
that she's like hog-tied calf rope me
yeah and it's like i'm gonna ride like a
rhodium like there's not a horse on the
planet lady someone from a yellowstone
is gonna be wrapping a lasso around her
horns that is the saddest toilet on
earth in that bathroom
[Laughter]
it's the only toilet that's hoping to be
picked last for gym class yes please
don't use me
that's the pee wee herman
she bought me at an auction i'm always
choking yeah
when the toilet is yearning for the days
of king kong bundy um maybe you
shouldn't be doing a celebratory video
we have a problem with baby gender
reveal parties but we're doing weight
gain celebrations she does it every day
because her weight just continues to
tick up so
that's the that's just not an
accomplishment in my book
well for her it is she's pretty high
it's hard once you get the weight up
there yeah you know it's kind of like
when you lose weight then the last
couple pounds are hardest to shave off
right once you effectively have to go to
a weighing station
it's like it's tough you know it's tough
to get that extra eight ounces once
you're past the 405 mark yeah like if a
couple boxes fall off a truck nobody's
gonna notice we make a profit right
exactly what you say exactly yeah
someone give her a tlc show
and uh here's something else that's
happening unfortunately uh this is what
the state of our uh of our country is we
were talking about the ronald mcdonald
house the other day yeah oh by the way
we have judge fauci on the show today do
we really as he's commonly referred to
the science i'm glad the science will be
here yeah the science will be here
a four-year-old boy with uh leukemia uh
has now been evicted
from the ronald mcdonald house and this
is in canada uh so in british columbia
because i know some americans like
britain no
british it's a silly place they still
have the queen on their money it's the
only country that gained its right to be
a country by just saying uncle right to
the royalty everybody else threw off the
shackles except oh my gosh i cannot
stand canada
and i am it
british columbia this kid's kicked out
of a ronald mcdonald house
because he isn't vaccinated so we have a
video here of the pissed off dad it is
uh heartbreaking
but uh this is
just remember this when the left tries
to say that they're the party of
compassion
remember this oh this is a piece of
paper come on lizzie's zoom in on it
this is an eviction notice i believe to
anybody older than five who's not
vaccinated is getting evicted from
ronald mcdonald house so i'm gonna go
talk to people at the counter as if he
was legit
they send out eviction notices
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
my four-year-old boy leukemia is getting
evicted
because we don't have a vaccine
this is if he was six months old
that looks like spina bifida
you're going to say gollum itis
yeah first off uh the most important
thing is that lady has
disproportionately short legs she looks
like when i do the bit of uh like i'm a
[ __ ] but i put my knees in slippers
yeah
we have a grace period no grace is the
other girl you evicted and died four
weeks ago and this is just we're going
dwarf on science hold on a second isn't
the ronald mcdonald house for kids who
are sick yeah isn't the whole point to
help people who are sick
and the mcdonald's is for people who
want to get sick yes absolutely yeah
well they're not loving it after they no
they go
you're leaving without care but
your killer t cell count doesn't exist
you're hurting families this is just
absolutely uh heartbreaking yeah and the
way they justified as well look look
this is the ronald mcdonald house
we have kids here with cancer we have
kids here with uh spinal meningitis we
have kids here with sickle cell and if
you're not vaccinated they could get the
sniffles
and by the way if you are vaccinated
they can still get the sniffles
apparently right yeah we just want to
give them a completely non-experimental
totally effective vaccine right yeah
well it comes in a happy meal now it's
just the hamburglar yeah it's true and
it just sticks you in the neck it's just
a syringe that's filled with it one of
the fry kids give it to you yeah and
ground up beanie babies yeah while
grimace gets a
whatever transgender surgery what is
grimace boy or girl what do you think we
should not say yeah we shouldn't say we
shouldn't it's true grimace is the first
uh genitalia i'm not entirely convinced
that if lizzo unzips her fat suit she
isn't grimaced under she might be the
cookie monster surprise [ __ ]
so let me just tell you something about
canada okay and specifically my home
province of quebec um they are to give
you a list in all references available
at lottlecredit.com imposing a health
contribution tax on the unvaccinated
okay uh they've banned dog walking
during curfew 10 p.m to 5 a.m uh they're
mandating vaccines for liquor and
cannabis stores because by god if people
aren't vaccinated something could go
wrong at the local liquor store i love
the cannabis store part if you want to
get high you got to have a vaccine
you're good at sticking your arm right
come on vaccine after next
yeah really the only thing that you can
rely on is being blind drunk that's the
healthiest thing for a society
absolutely yeah i was getting it
vaccinated but it was blood stinking
drunk name that movie line and they're
soon going to be mandating a booster
shot which just seems like why do any of
this at this point and um also the um
you know some of you know him as prime
minister justin trudeau and a lot of you
say he's a guy who does a black face
like every other tuesday
i know him as the biggest piece of [ __ ]
who's ever lived ah yes so um depending
on i just want to make sure that uh
you're all familiar uh he was asked
on a french canadian show
and i speak french so i might have to
translate if you're listening on audio
here uh you know there are subtitles
what bothers me is he's actually
speaking the right wrong french he's
speaking in general and french canadian
accent yeah he corrects them so in other
words it would be like me
it's just like when biden would say they
want to put you all back in chains well
like when hillary clinton's exactly
exactly he's doing that with the french
and you know the left is the party
they're the compassionate party we just
saw they want to make sure that we get
rid of kids from ronald mcdonald houses
now this is not some kind of uh
extremist view this is the mainstream
view of the left platform this is the
mainstream view of the country that
exists that is most similar to america
they're supposed to be compassionate
tolerant and here he is actually using
those words
prime minister blackface himself saying
we shouldn't tolerate these people and
by the way these people uh these are you
know the enemies of the state as uh joe
biden former vice president biden would
put it uh but really just the unbaxed
listen to this man
so a couple of things there first off
are you seeing the pattern here
when he says uh
he's saying 80 of quebecers are
vaccinated so we won't tolerate these
people do you see why democracy doesn't
work do you see why mob rule is a lie do
you understand why it's important that
we're a constitutional republic it
doesn't matter if eighty percent of
quebecers are vaccinated seventy percent
of them marry their cousins
so the rule that they always do
justifies well most australians are okay
with it so uh you should go to your self
quarantine cam well most quebecers are
okay with it therefore uh we shouldn't
tolerate these people who are
unvaccinated and he throws in there he
says these people who are and i'm sorry
my brain i keep going back from french
to english saying there are these
extremist groups uh who are opposed to
the vaccination they're usually racist
they're usually misogynist hold on a
second what are the most vaccine
hesitant groups can i just
minorities and pregnant women
yes but they're racist and misogynist
against themselves they can't help but
fit it in they can't help it just say
hey look we're totalitarian okay i
believe in mob rule 80 of people are
vaccinated even though right now
basically your outcome is the same with
omicron vaccinated or unvaccinated
that's a fact at this point look what
happens if you're vaccinated you don't
end up in the hospital er you probably
have mild symptoms what happens if
you're unvaccinated you don't end up in
the er possible mild symptoms at this
point there is
what's the argument that we're having
and by the way when these people blame
the unvaccinated they're still locking
down in countries where they are almost
entirely vaccinated why do you need any
rules in quebec if it's 80 vaccinated
right you're well past any threshold
that was supposed to be met for hurt
immunity this is are you starting to
understand this has nothing
to do with science and everything to do
with control does it have to get to 90
does it have to get to 99 before you
start rounding up the unvaxed and
blaming them for the biggest spike in
the history of this pandemic at what
point do you say huh maybe it's not the
unvaccinated maybe we have the biggest
spike ever if you were just playing a
percentages game because of the 80
percent who are vaccinated
and it still doesn't give you the right
to strip people of their rights it still
doesn't give you the right to kick some
poor kid with leukemia
out of the ronald mcdonald house
this is where we are in canada and
that's what they did in australia too
they closed down the entire country for
four days you if you were unvaccinated
you couldn't leave the house to go to
work right right and so a lot of people
you're like oh well you get a four day
weekend no no a lot of people are hourly
a lot of people can't afford to miss
that four days right where's your
compassion for people who are making
minimum wage in most countries but
leaders around the world have doubled
down and said this is the unvaccinated
there's a danish study right now and i
think one in ontario that says it's
about three times more transmissible
among vaccinated than delta was this is
not an unvaccinated versus vax no matter
how many times former vice president joe
biden says it and president kamala
harris his words not mine right it is
a virus that is spreading through both
communities yes stop live your lives
there's a certain point where you have
to make it it's done well yeah a
four-day weekend when you're a grown-up
it's not like hey guys it's seeing you
skip day we're all gonna go to the moon
tower on vacs
it ruins a lot of people's lives yeah
we're gonna skip the science fair and
head down to the convenience store with
a fake id yeah it's gonna be pretty
awesome liquor store's still open right
especially when you gotta be coming back
and don't get vaccinated you get fired
anyway this is canada where he says
should we tolerate these people oh
should we tolerate people who are not
getting an experimental injection no no
just tolerate the kind of behavior that
leads to uh aids hiv across your country
or in your state of california and
tolerate non-disclosure laws yeah that's
absolutely true you can have hiv aids in
california and it's illegal for as
someone is bending over before you allow
him for him to go oh wait a second you
don't have hiv do you do you have a
warrant i don't have to answer that
question
this is what they're tolerant of but not
the kid in the ronald mcdonald house who
doesn't want to get vaccinated because
he's immune compromised and we don't
know the reaction i'm not going to let
you in my ass without a warrant yeah
exactly
it's a no knock well okay i'm good with
that all right i'm a fan of stop and
frisk if you know what i mean yeah yeah
stop in first it's an it's an it's a no
plow warrant
i just
who human uh the human race is a failed
experiment yeah at this point i would
say we screwed it up yeah this is our
fault uh the internet's ruined
everything and now there's how many
people have to be vaccinated for a
vaccine to work i imagine it's quite
under 80 percent yeah and i'm completely
pro vax everybody i just don't think
in my opinion this one works
and i'm just going off you know the
numbers the boosters right the fact that
i'm now finally seeing people on the
left saying they don't want the boosters
people are starting to realize i don't
know what's the word oh it's [ __ ]
yeah you mean when the pfizer ceo
himself comes out and says that it
provided very little protection unless
you get like what's first booster maybe
second booster and then they they
copyright struck their own video to pull
him down before he clutched his heart
and descended into his pine overcoat
yeah now uh moving on from failed uh uh
experiment of the human condition joy
reed and i always have to verify that
it's joy reading see the clip because
i'm like is that joy reid
is that someone doing a joy read
impression is that lizzo
grimace no all the clips i'm about to
show you are joy read and i know it's
very you'll see why it's so confusing
yeah um she's also in favor of not only
medical discrimination but this is the
irony here there's no consistency right
i want you this is the theme today
compassion and tolerance that's what the
left has said that's why i don't use the
term compassionate conservative because
i think allowing people to make their
own decisions and be free is
compassionate enough i don't think
there's anything compassionate about
spending somebody else's money which the
pharmaceutical companies have done but
where are the people who used to [ __ ]
about big pharma they're gone i digress
so joy reid
compassionate right she was
compassionate about
obamacare about the affordable care act
about the public option about not
denying people for pre-existing
conditions about making sure that
everybody gets health care and that
people don't have to pay for it because
it comes from a magical land of
chocolate rivers and sunshine farts or
nancy pelosi spins recycled trash into
golden yarn and insulin shots or epipens
so she was all about the socialized
healthcare then cost was not an issue
but now
joy reid we just went from canada joy
reid thinks that uh the unvaxed because
they're the reason for the surge there
yeah need to pay more here you go let's
talk about what other countries are
doing because at some point i feel like
people who are willfully unvaccinated
don't get vaccinated
of what this is doing to our system
uh there are fines that that are that
are levied in places like germany
germany has stopped paying for the tests
the virus tests for people who choose to
be unvaccinated they've ended quarantine
pay for those without vaccinations ikea
the company is slashing sick pay for
unvaccinated uk workers if you are a
smoker
insurance companies can charge you more
they can charge you a premium up to 50
and you have to put that on the forum
when you apply for insurance at some
point don't we have to make people who
are just saying i'm willing to take the
risk to be unvaccinated take the risk
for me and take the risk for everyone i
come in contact with shouldn't they have
to pay more into the system because they
are collapsing our health system they're
the ones in the ers
uh now a couple of things uh everything
she just said is incorrect but
i guess i don't need to say much more
than that but here's something that's
pretty interesting of the this actually
comes from uh kaiser permanente uh of
the 52 000 infected with omicron not one
person needed a ventilator people with
omicron are 91 percent less likely to
die they're 74 percent less likely to be
admitted to intensive care and by the
way this is across vaxxed and unvaxed
ah now it would be one thing if she was
saying you know if you're going for
insurance you have to check the box that
you're a smoker it's like
oh okay so
you agree with that no no i think it's
an invasion of privacy so you also think
it's an invasion of no no you should
have to check a box if your vaxxer on
backs how about a little bit of
consistency i think that if you're a
smoker you probably have to pay more for
insurance i understand that i think if
you're a black tar heroin addict you
probably should sign that on the form i
also think that fine if insurance
companies want you to list that your
baxter unbacks well look then they need
to prove that there's a discernible
health outcome difference
they can't do that right now we know
that if you smoke you're more likely to
get lung cancer well if you have a
breakthrough case that though it means
you have super covet and it's actually
your fault for the spike so you should
pay the tax you should pay for everyone
else's car that's what i think if
there's one more mutation because of a
leaky vaccine i think that the makers of
the vaccine should have to pay
all of the costs for uh the new mutated
virus that seems like a good idea yeah
it's going to be adamantium coveted nice
well joey reed never misses an
opportunity to peddle the lie that if
you're vaccinated this is what she said
by insinuation that if you're
vaccinations you start peddling a bike
you'll see the next clip you'll know
what i'm talking about she really lives
up to her name
not joy at all but she can't read no she
never misses an opportunity to peddle
the lie that if you're vaccinated you
can't spread this virus because she said
if you're unvaccinated you're willing to
take that chance for everybody else i'm
sorry what yeah because you can still
spread it if you're vaccinated now let's
contrast that and then former vice
president biden is speaking right now oh
he hasn't updated his hair plugs but
we'll go down after this because he
always says he's looking into the sun in
a dark room well that's he's trying to
he's looking for the sun it's good
to look at it where is it can someone
point me my eyes in the direction of the
sun he's trying not to die on camera
yeah
he just had his third booster [ __ ] his
pants joe don't look into the light you
said that's the laugh he just took the
kid's bed at the ronald mcdonald house
yeah he digs every time he sees the sun
he thinks he's going home to the lord
today's the day just starts walking into
the horizon and doesn't realize that the
water is getting deeper i can't have
trouble breathing
um
he'll know when he dies because demon
hands will grab him and pull him to hell
it'll look like the cover of strangers
with nothing ringing the doorbell so uh
or frighteners whatever it is i don't
care contrast this with joy reid an
absolute joy who can't read uh her
support of universal healthcare the
affordable care act and of course her
screeching about the idea that health
insurance companies might be able to
decline you for pre-existing conditions
which is almost the entire idea of
insurance to begin with but here's joy
read then
aside from the sort of pragmatic issues
you know alabama county it got five
still george mass for the national
stockholm we've got a lot on the federal
healthcare system to make sure that if
you go in and you're treated for covid19
you know who pays for that who pays for
the test that you're getting why is ray
romano million people in counting who've
been sold
contracted the corona virus if even if
they survive it then have a pre-existing
condition it looks to me like
republicans are trying to indemnify
insurance companies from having to cover
those people that would be the outcome
if the aca went away right
absolutely
so he could say yeah you got to cover
pre-existing conditions but what he
doesn't say
is that you cannot charge for more if
they have a pre-existing condition
so she actually really was championing
the idea that insurance companies
shouldn't be able to charge you any more
even if you don't have insurance and say
i have kovit and i would like insurance
now right however now she draws the line
at being unvaxed well actually the
headline stephen is that joy reid wants
to tax minorities yeah because
minorities tend to make up a large
proportion of the unfacts also she wants
to tax women yes that's the headline i'm
sorry that's what it is if you guys are
going to play this game so can we you
want to tax minorities joy reid sorry
yeah also she wants to subsidize uh wig
manufacturers
it's true well she is subsidizing look
either you came back from a cruise with
those crappy little beads in your hair
i don't know if that's a tattoo that's
going to wash off in a week i just had a
man bun in one of those yeah she had a
man bun yeah she was trying out for the
european soccer team she made it by the
way stop it i'm for somebody who i wish
there was a universal health care
because i do believe that if somebody's
extraordinarily sick they should get
help jesus never asked for a copay he
did but no he didn't he did no he didn't
do you missed it no second thessalonians
yeah
but
he also referred he also put uh tax
collectors in the same plane as
prostitutes
yeah i agree yeah yeah but that's how
you get socialized hence the same thing
i know it's how you get socialized
healthcare i'm not saying socialize
healthcare or universal healthcare
putting a political label on it right i
mean somebody who's sick should be able
to get help that's my point yes and all
we've done is
we've com
i just hate everything i'm just no no no
no finish your point you know i
understand exactly what you're saying
but this is again the compassionate
version of that as a conservative
looking at the free well there should be
a compassionate version of it and
there's not everything's politicized
it's the same thing that she just went
out there and said yeah it's the same
thing where when it was donald trump you
want to sit there and go against him
when he's trying to do the right thing
now all of a sudden you have this
[ __ ] in office and she's going she's
going against her own words yeah and
going against her own people going
against pregnant women yeah 80 of the
population is vexed what else do you
want to prove that this thing doesn't
seem to work uh 82 in canada gotcha
that's it no i'm just kidding like it's
been 93 years of utter nonsense yeah and
the only thing they're doing is screwing
the american public more by trying to
put a tax yeah on people who are like
hey i don't think that thing's gonna
work why would you pump something that
you're not even sure would work into a
four year that's also something who's
dying that's also going to say there's
no reason to not get vaccinated but
we'll get to that in a second listen
lottery agree with them they're playing
there
those are good reasons right now uh
let's look at a bad reason to currently
cross the border caravan
the former vice president at the helm
but my point though is being unvaxed is
not a condition no right it's not no
bottom line cancer is a pre-existing
condition sure there's certain things
you may have had that are a condition
not taking certain medicine is not a
condition right bottom line yeah being
joyride is a pre-existing condition yeah
it's yeah there's a pre-existing sea in
there i mean i wouldn't admit her to
saint jude's no
now uh she loves ronald mcdonald's house
yeah let's see let's see what uh former
vice president joe biden is saying he
looks very confused reimbursed for eight
tests a month why is your right hand
insurance we have over 20 stroke phases
oh right free testing just having
endless strokes you can find the nearest
testing sites for you oh shut up by
googling
test near me google covered
how stupid do the democrats think you
are no i know a lot of you don't know uh
you don't know where to find a test you
don't know what a test is some of you
don't you can't even finish the word
test you just you go to
it's asked
that's how you finish the word so if you
go to uh this uh multi-hundred million
dollar government bureaucratic website
we have something that you could
actually uh do yourself within 40
seconds on google maps
we have governed tests near me it was
going to be coveted tests but some kid
bought it and he wouldn't sell it to me
military and other federal emergency
personnel have been deployed to 24
states tribes and territories
including over 350 military doctors
nurses and medics helping staff the
hospitals around supply i needed this on
time i only had the home test but i
wanted the pcr
if you feel sick it's important to go to
cova test near me then stand in a cold
line for an hour and a half while
feeling ill lowering your body
temperature by an average of 1.6 degrees
fahrenheit i was trying to find my local
testing center but my phone
is only the 4g it's not the lte you need
to pay for that too yeah
hey yeah yeah we're crying out loud
really we need this is the emergency
think about this for a second the
emergency broadcast right now from this
president used to be like emergency
broadcast hey everyone get under your
desk kiss your ass goodbye because the
russians have nukes the emergency
broadcast right now is hey look there's
a virus out there right now that leads
to no
requiring of a ventilator according to
kaiser permanente incredibly low death
rates incredibly low serious infection
rates right now we have a high surge of
cases but the death the mortality rate
has not proportionately increased and by
the way we have this epidemic where so
many of you out there as i understand it
don't know where to go to get a test so
please let me interrupt the price is
right for this [ __ ] right and we're
going to buy 500 million more tests we
the government no no no we the people
are buying 500 million more tests that's
our tax dollars at work and by the way
you know what happens if you test
positive for covid right now
they send you a home no they do they
send you home and they say hey but
unlike the price is right you have no
prizes well that's true you get zero
prizes and the doctor is going to call
you and give you instructions you know
what that call was that i didn't receive
by the way sorry an hour later no call
five days later no call 10 days later no
call
nothing yeah you get nothing okay so
here's that idea if you're sick right
now just quarantine yourself until
you're not sick i know that that's crazy
like stay away from people if you're
sick i think we've heard this before our
entire lives like if you're sick don't
come into work
don't worry about going and getting a
test yeah also if you're sick don't come
into the ronald mcdonald house well then
where should i go the streets let's see
what else he's saying well same massive
corporations like pfizer who would you
know screw you over if you didn't come
into work are the ones that are now
enforcing all yeah by the way do we get
any money i'm going to be giving you
some numbers on what we've funded as far
as these vaccines hey any of you seen
your check in the mail for the profits
that's another issue right when we're
talking about the little guy we're
talking about socialism we're talking
about the bernie sanders and the
elizabeth warrens hey hold on a second
we all right we socialize the funding of
it we've socialized the losses for these
companies what about the profits any of
you received your check in the mail
let's see what what else he's saying
look he's smiling like he's smelling his
own farts and you've just been listening
to president biden
that the administration is taking to
come
now okay they're not combating the surge
if they give you tests they're tracking
the surge i tell you what this is
it really is just enough already
shut up and do something i'm not
entirely convinced that we're not being
manipulated by big surge that energy
drink is making a comeback that's true
everybody's gonna be drinking surge
you're looking where to find uh
a test and then it's just channing tatum
going with a dune buggy surge like oh
skunked again they were the same
commercials except they'd be in like a
jeep riding a wave instead of a
surfboard like mountain dew and then
they would scream surge hey speaking of
which build bar yeah uh these are this i
have lost about 35 pounds you have yeah
and a big part of it was i just use
these billboards these protein bars
because they taste like candy bars this
double chocolate right here tastes like
a three musketeers bar but they don't
have those annoying friends friends
dresser commercials no no
a soldier's ass yeah
built.com
uh use the promo code crowder15 really
they really are delicious there's real
chocolate in there too real dark
chocolate i love them they have the
balls to sponsor this show and it did
help me lose weight really did i like it
it satisfies that craving at night uh
you know speaking of night
the next person we're about to discuss
is the kind of person who gives children
nightmares oh
no come on yeah yeah do you guys know
who i'm about to talk about before we
just before we get to the vice
i sense a rain dance yes no no no it's
not uh uh phillips uh nathan phillips oh
as or as he's known uh uh among his uh
tribesmen
nate no is that the death head nate meth
headname yeah headmate is it the let's
have a beer every woman yes exactly it
is elizabeth warren who just tweeted
this video blaming record high inflation
right now
on wait we need some who is it it's a
big kroger
think of the example right now for
example with grocery stores remember how
many grocery stores there used to be and
now what you've got is a handful of them
where'd you get your pow-wow
and then what happens
kroger uh their profits just in the
third quarter of 2021 were almost 900
million dollars that was more than three
times what their profits were
periods in 2019. now
if they are able to expand profits not
expand prices expand profits
that's because they have a lot of market
dominance here
if we move in dominance like you with
your husband break up these giant
corporations
then we get real competition and then we
get markets that are truly competitive
that's good for small businesses it's
good for consumers
and it actually in many cases reduces
the need for regulatory oversight you
can count on the markets doing what they
need to do anytime elizabeth warren
implies that she wants to reduce the
need for regulatory oversight you know
she's lying do i am i going out on a
limb saying that i think you all believe
me right you can comment below does
anyone actually think elizabeth warren
wakes do you think any day in her life
her head is popped off the pillow and
she's going i've been wrong about
government bureaucracy
well how about the fact that she has no
opinion and just goes out and panders at
every opportunity what possible and then
fails at it every time yeah and this is
the problem is look i'm not the party of
big business or small business i'm the
party of good business let's get to the
pharmaceutical companies in a little bit
who elizabeth warren has supported
through your tax dollars but she's
vilifying kroger this is just another
attack and they're trying to throw you
off the scent remember when biden blamed
uh he blamed the meat industry for the
rising meat prices yeah it's just what's
the meat industry okay i'm sure they
just woke up one day and decided yeah
we're just gonna double the price of
everything we could double price hot
dogs yes yes exactly
it's uh seven percent year-over-year
inflation in uh december here the most
in 40 years yeah that just came out
yesterday right most since 1982 by the
way do you remember what happened in
1982 when we were going from the georgia
peanut farmer to ronald reagan yeah
you're the price for money was like 18
for a home loan so you guys that are
crapping on a 3
think about eighteen percent i thought
you were gonna say that they were
wearing uh fewer sweaters in the white
house well they probably were uh now
grocery store food prices they went up
by six and a half percent over the last
12 months okay now here's the thing
she's vilifying grocery stores now
maybe that they may or may not be making
decent money i'll get to the numbers
they're not but
it doesn't matter
if we're not subsidizing them again it's
none of my business if a company is not
raping you of your tax dollars so let's
get to some of the operating costs in
the profit margins i don't know why she
i know exactly why she set out to vilify
kroger because they need a scapegoat
because it's horrible the inflation is
horrible the economy is horrible and
here's a surefire way that democrats
lose right is you go to the grocery
store and you just uh look at the things
and you go wow
this is bad and so they need to say no
no the reason that you're looking at
those things is not because of anything
that we've done even though you had
three years four years of those things
being far less expensive relatively
speaking the reason you're looking at
those things is because of big piggly
wiggly so uh grocery stores they're
operating margins nationally retail food
and grocery stores is about 2.5
oh wow last quarter kroger had an
operating margin of one point nine
five percent damn you big damn
1.95
now think about this you fat cats
they're vilifying these people while
saying hey you need to be vaccinated so
you can go to your liquor stores and
support your local cannabis stores well
think about it in the alcohol industry
they're operating margins 21
pharmaceutical drugs 24
metal and mining 25 percent it is one of
the worst operating margins in the
entire
economy yes grocery store when you have
a business as an entrepreneur i've had
these conversations like it is a joke
that you say like we don't want to be a
grocery store because you don't want to
operate on razor thin profit margins
five percent is considered low
nationally across all industries five
percent is low five percent for them and
they're popping champagne ten percent is
average so i don't know what do you want
they're twenty they're 80 percent below
the average what else do you want i'm
sorry that they made 900 million 82 82.
i want them 82 below
i want to reach it's always more stephen
i want to reach herd poverty
well once we're at 80 i think we'll be a
better country yes i think we'll be a
better off country i think the only
worst company uh business going is uh
being a florist because yeah uh no come
on really i knew someone who ran it some
you know someone in chat let me know if
you're a florist i knew someone who ran
a flower shop and she she said like you
have roses are so expensive i know it's
perishable but you know well there's a
lot of there's a lot of uh there's a lot
of money that goes into productivity you
know why
do you know what is required to make a
good rose do you have any idea no love
water now big flora has been bending us
over a sofa for the last 20 years big
botany that's why they invented
valentine's day those jerks and sweetest
days
those are too big to fail
horticulturalists now um
keep in mind uh while we're talking
about a 1.95
operating margin now you may not like it
because you hear 300 million and you go
that sounds like a lot of millions
and you only have so many of those
however many it is my point is i know
that you don't have that many and i
don't have that many so it's easy to be
jealous again the democrats aren't
compassion they compassionate they just
want to capitalize on your greed guess
what i'm a conservative i'm not
capitalizing on your greed by saying
yeah keep what you earn
and i'll keep what i earn yeah i'm
capitalizing on your greed if i say hey
you
see what he ha see what dave has you
should take what dave has and you know
what we'll help you by sending in guys
with guns also uh we're going to take
away dave's guns this is what they want
to do now let me give you an example of
profit margins you know a place where
you get a crazy return on investment is
if you go into public office just watch
nancy pelosi as her face gets stretched
over like a used condom her forehead
increasingly
and she
she ardently she passionately defends uh
not incorporating any sort of
anti-insider trading laws for your
representatives and secondly you should
members of congress tales from the crypt
no i don't know to the second one um
any uh we have a responsibility to
report
in the stock
on the stock but i don't i'm not
familiar with that five-month review but
if the people aren't reporting they
should be
because this is a free market in people
we have free market economy they should
be able to participate in that okay now
look let me just explain something
really quickly to you guys
people who don't understand um
and this is something important because
you hear people a lot a lot of the time
they throw in oh insider trading it
should apply to people in congress and
to a lot of folks who necessarily don't
necessarily pay attention to the news
every day let me
let me at least illuminate a little bit
here why it's a problem compared to
someone who's not in public office so
for example martha stewart's got in
trouble because of insider trading if
you work for a company and you let
someone else know
i don't know hey this company right now
is going to be coming out with a new
product tomorrow you should invest in it
immediately and we're going to see a
tripling of our profits and someone
actually takes that tip and invest this
is insider trading it's illegal right
it's illegal for you the citizen here's
what's not illegal and why it's a
problem let me make it really simple for
you and everyone here can let me know if
if i've made if i've been reductive
enough i want to be reductive nancy
pelosi okay nancy pelosi representative
or let's say uh uh uh aoc in new york
okay aoc is a representative of new york
any senator take your pick they can say
oh wait a second you know what i'm
actually going to uh put a moratorium on
that drilling uh until you jump through
these hoops and then if you do you know
what we'll lift it next thursday and
they invest a bunch of money in the
stock of that company wednesday that's
not illegal for them to do because it's
not insider trading they're the ones who
are simply manipulating the laws that
determine the market
that's the kind of laws that we want
applied to our representatives does
everyone understand does that make it
simple for you to understand it does
fair fair playing field whatever i have
to live by they should have to live by
and right now they're not there's a
story of i won't tell it
there's a story of there's a story of
the ufc i don't know if this is true or
not there was a story of the ufc before
it was bought by some uh current uh some
owners not the current owners but what
happened was the ufc was in the dark
ages okay they were in the dark ages
john mccain was referring to it as human
[ __ ] fighting and uh they had to host
them on indian uh grounds try first
nations grounds first
basically it was nathan phillips with a
shark hunting light going all right dude
let's turn it on
so they had to host them on indian
gaming casinos and it wasn't legal it
wasn't sanctioned by any commission a
company bought the ufc for pennies on
the dollar and they had somebody i don't
know if this is true or not but this is
just an example i'm using so this is
allegedly they had someone on the nevada
state athletic commission who was
holding out on sanctioning mixed martial
arts until the company was sold it was
sold and then it became a mainstream
sport
this is the kind of thing that can
happen if legislators can hold up laws
and determine how markets work
of course their portfolio is going to
grow why do you think their net worth
grows at a rate that is exponentially
higher than yours when their salary is
somewhere around 170 thousand dollars
just do the math now here's something
else what we're talking about elizabeth
warren bitching about big kroger this is
the same woman who determined that
blackrock the company by the way who
managed they managed trillions of
dollars in assets and they're the ones
who've been buying up all of these
houses so that of course you'll have a
permanent class of renters we've talked
about blackrock references available at
credit.com this is the same elizabeth
warren who said that that company
should be too big to fail and get a
never-ending supply of your taxpayer uh
dollar bailout secretary yellen just
hypothetically if a 9 trillion dollar
investment company failed would that
likely have a significant impact on our
economy
well senator warren i believe it's
important to look very carefully
at the risk posed by asset management
including blackrock and other firms
poltergeists are upstairs
um designation
correct is the correct tool to address
right now wait just a minute designation
is what gives you fed it's increased
oversight power is that correct
is that correct
yes and is blackrock currently
designated so that it receives that
increased oversight
it it isn't designated but i think it's
important to understand so that means it
is not receiving the increased oversight
from the fed when the party is going
strong it's the job of the regulators to
take away the punch bowl uh by the way
we have confirmed in fact that janet
yelling yelling is a paddling uh just
for people who are wondering that's
right good good now notice she just said
hey oversight we want wasn't she just
saying hey it can reduce the need for
oversight when she was talking about
kroger so that was a good thing so
here's the argument they make when they
say too big to fail keep in mind
companies that are too big to fail case
you're wondering companies that you love
like banks airlines american auto
manufacturers you know stuff you like so
these are the companies that are all too
big to fail what she's saying though is
if we make this black rock too big to
fail which means they will be bailed out
by you in perpetuity no matter how badly
they screw up but we get more oversight
oh that's the pot of gold at the end of
the rainbow
see how it's inconsistent
no company should be too big to fail
none it's ridiculous never and by the
way i just want to point out that janet
yellen is leading an organization whose
goal is to have two percent inflation
they have every monetary tool available
and we just saw
seven these are the smartest people in
the room guys
okay
i'm screwed right aiming for two percent
inflation always that is that that is
the fed's goal no but forever i know but
i thought she would have you know just
lifted it a little bit because there was
no chance that we're gonna get i mean
it's three and a half times like did i
say two
i meant uh nine
so we're really doing pretty well with
seven well yeah it's not too shabby yeah
it could be worse could it could have
been nine which is what we told you it
would be but instead we came in with
seven so uh you know congratulations to
me
yeah i think [ __ ] with the housing
market's a great idea yeah let's go back
to that yeah with a name that rhymes
with crack rock yes
how do you think they get their funding
exactly who do you think they're gearing
it towards in the most non-racist way
they think uh by the way while we're
talking about uh well we're talking
about funding uh it's time to actually i
think we have him um oh no we've had him
on the show before you you know him as
the science uh we know him as of course
uh judge fauci uh we have now judge
fouchy do we have him do we have on the
line we have judge fauci to discuss the
new uh omicron variant
[Music]
okay so do we have a uh judge fauci can
you hear me sir hello
steven yes
is the science speaking okay uh dr fauci
um listen i wanted to ask you about this
because it's been going viral how did
you feel about rand paul
really going at you pretty hard uh with
some facts on
herd immunity uh and the omicron variant
on tuesday this is everywhere i am the
science okay yeah that's not an answer
though i don't no it's i don't think
that's the answer we're well i think
we're finding now hard evidence
that um that uh that uh that i am the
science no we're not finding hard
evidence to that at all
that you're a liar
rand paul threatened to kill the science
and i
and the science no no no no he didn't
threaten to kill you at all he just rand
paul didn't threaten you at all he just
thinks that you should be fired
which would kill the science okay okay i
don't know which i am no that's no no no
no that's okay
[Music]
this guy really thinks he's the science
doesn't he you know answer for
everything
man
i believe every word he says all the
time yeah no i don't oh you don't no i
wear three masks sometimes
when i'm alone in my car can we start
fire dave campaign okay really quickly
let me go through you mean pay him more
because he has to listen to you
oh
son of a [ __ ]
let's get to pfizer and big pharma money
yeah sorry they were not feeling time
for me because i had a i had a mess up
with the other
crazy i was judge fouchy he doesn't have
a good connection as his problem yeah
you'd think the science could invest in
some headphones
no
so here's something else by the way
have you seen those ears yeah have you
guys been
well it doesn't matter i don't know i
don't care if people are vaccinated i
don't care anymore what difference does
it make
well you could mean you could have a job
yeah well you know what
it's just i don't know you can find one
stroked out on the floor and ask yeah
that's true just ask a soccer player
having a heart attack yeah perfectly
healthy five weeks ago the director of
dallas buyers club getting his third
booster and uh guess who he gets to me
to the star of death yes exactly who was
written about yeah if you see a
four-year-old with a leather helmet
riding on the floor that's you know
that's what i mean in other words that's
the difference that it makes but as a
general rule i don't really care if
you're vaccinated or not i don't care if
kroger makes money or not here's what i
they should it's a business
incredible idea crazy ideas novel idea i
think we should reach herd poverty
that's what we're going for i look this
is why you come here for hot takes
herd
poverty when everybody
and there's just a class of rich rich
government that always ends well well i
wasn't talk
yes but you're discussing venezuela i'm
talking about you heard poverty
heard poverty exactly it's never been
done not right correctly true true
so
um
last week
india usually a nation of which i'm not
a fan right
uh is it bombay is it mumbai pick a lane
now bollywood no idea they uh
flagged merck's new coveted pill for
major safety concerns the head of
india's council of medical research
balram balgarva said and you know what
the show hasn't really been offensive
enough so i'll read the quote we have to
remember that this drug has major safety
concerns
it can cause terror this oh god good
luck going with the accident it can
cause teratogenicity
mutagenesis city and it can also cause
cartilage damage and be damaging to
muscles which i clearly do not have
more importantly contraception will have
to be used for three months if this drug
is given because the child born could be
problematic with
teratogenic influences these are medical
terms for flippers
[Laughter]
you know arkansas and this is a country
where we poop in the street your kid
will be a great swimmer but we don't
have water
it's clean not clean what we know so
india said no we're not going to do this
now keep in mind merc has been selling
this pill at 40 times the production oh
cool yeah well we're talking we're
bitching about kroger perk 40 times the
production cost they also sell merkins
at twice as much yeah now here's my
problem with this and i want to be very
clear let me rattle off some yeah
some stats for you the issue here is
privatizing profits and socializing
losses i want you know what comment
below and by the way smash that like
button if you're watching right now
smash the like button if you have no
intention of being vaccinated
let's consider this a poll if you have
no intention of being vaccinated
just smash it so we know it's like a
poll i'm not telling you not to get
vaccinated but smash it if you uh
if you don't plan on it that's all is
that okay that's okay yeah let's see
it's your choice um
and okay look the pill from merck 30
million dollars was used from the nih
and
dod okay i don't have a problem if the
pill is developed privately and it works
or
if the pill maybe works but has side
effects and you are allowed to make that
choice see pro-choice i think you should
be able to take experimental drugs if
you and your own healthcare provider
determine that it is appropriate i just
don't want to have to pay for said drugs
and i certainly don't want to be
mandated to take them myself i hope i've
been clear about this for you is that
something that's clear does everyone
understand where we're coming from
before you start calling us the fascists
and you demand our money to fund drugs
that we then have to take whether we
need to or not let me give you some
other examples pfizer they had 18.9
billion dollars in uh q2 revenue okay
their earnings rose 73
over the past year their operating
margin remember it was about 1.9 with
kroger yeah yeah who elizabeth warren
felt the need to host a zoom call over
this is a 1.9 guys we really got to put
put a stop to this
what's the what's the comparable
operating margin for pfizer oh 31
what are you serious yeah that's better
than drugs no i'm not serious sorry it's
30.84 i don't want to be booted see
that's different well look if you take
away all of their coveted money right i
think it goes down to like 10 percent
yeah right so that's a huge difference
they've only made a 20 profit off of
covid right or three times without covid
they only make an average of uh five uh
times the amount of credit more than
yeah well actually ten yeah
well one point nine i don't know the the
point is elizabeth warren
dominates her husband
that man is used to playing wheelbarrow
now
he just puts here's here's what here's
what else is interesting what we're
talking about these pharmaceutical drugs
revenues for their anti-clotting drug uh
eloqui
by the way not uh to be confused
eloquently lives in a new york apartment
new york hotel
uh eloqui is the anti-clotting drug it
rose 13 percent what we're talking about
oh that's uh well because according to
vares there have been uh over 1700
reports of blood clots after the pfizer
vaccine it's like a certain wine with
fish yeah you know and that could be one
percent of uh the total blood clotting
complications but again we don't want to
you know jump to any conclusions now
sales of their heart medication while
we're talking about these pharmaceutical
companies who have operating margins
that are 30 times higher than kroger
vindical as a medication went up 77 now
to be clear according to various data
there have been 1400 reports of
myocarditis after fiser not including
other heart related complications and
the cdc even had a meeting about it so
it's not like it's something it's not
like i'm letting the cat out of the
scientific bag on that one and i know
some of you are saying well you can't
rely on varys well then you've never had
any data on any vaccine ever
because that's what's used
so um the stock went up one billion
dollars from 2019 to 2020.
and here's something else while we're
talking about vindiquil the medication
pfizer they're actually pushing for it
to be funded by medicare and that would
be 225 000 per year for this drug by
medicare here's my issue again i don't i
don't think that i've
subsidized the fair life milk at kroger
i probably have somewhere down the line
we basically end up subsidizing
everything but you understand my point
not the crystal light no crystal light
is subsidy free i'm sure i mean i'm
gonna have a third nipple on my forehead
by the time i'm 42 but i don't care it's
calorie-free and therefore it's
guilt-free now here's my issue is the
subsidization of these companies who
operate even with our subsidization at
crazy profit margins yet you don't hear
elizabeth warren calling them out let me
give you another example moderna how
much do you think that they received in
taxpayer funding through barda
a lot
955 million dollars i would oh not a lot
at all then yeah so not to mention by
the way the nih owns half the patent on
the vaccine that's twice what cylindra
got and we almost let the planet on fire
when that came out it's pretty bad wow
um what else do we have we have oh dr
barney graham he also created the spike
protein technology used in the mrna
vaccines and he owns the patent the
department of health spent 250 million
dollars the department of health and
when i say these i say department of
health i say barda just uh sort of in
your mind replace it with your wallet
250 million dollars in 2020 to convince
americans that the vaccine is safe so we
spent
billions of dollars
to develop this vaccine you me dave
we kind of went in threesies but david
hasn't paid his part yet we spent
billions of dollars to create these
vaccines that were so shitty we were
then required to pay another 250 million
dollars just to advertise to ourselves
that it's not as shitty as we know it to
be well and probably half of that was
because every democrat in the country
came out against donald trump's vaccine
while he was still president so they had
to erase all of that damage but they
made a magical new vaccine when biden
was elected it wasn't the same thing
yeah well you know madonna never even
brought a product to market but then
they got 100 million doses to the united
states so good for them um here's
something else too you say okay
yeah but stephen the why the why is the
question right that's the why would she
be going there's a reason she's going
after kroger and not going after pfizer
and moderna
johnson and johnson uh well they did it
to them it's easy johnson johnson an
inbred family company
um
several high several high profile biden
uh uh administration members have
financial ties to them that shouldn't
come as well johnson and johnson is just
docking yes
that's for me i prefer the term eskimo
leader
so biden science advisor dr eric lander
he holds between five hundred thousand
and a million dollars in bio and tech
stock he was uh actually conflicted out
of covet vaccine work until he divested
one million dollars of his stock
holdings congress won't take action
either since pfizer's pack donated to
guess how many
228 lawmakers
in 2020 228 lawmakers in 2020 let me
give you the names of some of the people
who have received money from pfizer and
by the way people can give money to
whoever they want i understand that
it wouldn't make a difference if we
didn't have to subsidize these company
look just just cut you can cut the head
off this is a this is a 19 headed beast
you can cut any one of them off at this
point and it'll die look fine hey they
can donate to whoever they want but
there's a law that says that uh we don't
subsidize these companies or okay you
know what they can't donate to anybody
or you know what okay hey if we're going
to subsidize them then we all reap the
benefit of the profits at the same time
so they don't socialize losses and
privatize profits the point is there are
so many points of contact here where you
are getting screwed
it's painfully clear the government
doesn't care about you it's painfully
clear that the democratic party doesn't
want what's best for you do you really
think that they believe what's best for
you is billions and when you add up all
the subsidies when you add up big banks
when you add up all these policies and
you add up the too big to fail hundreds
of billions trillions of dollars over
time do you really believe that they
think it's best for you to spend
billions of dollars in your tax dollars
that they don't have while
simultaneously printing more money so
that your money becomes worth less so
that they can prop up big pharmaceutical
companies who then take all of the
profits for themselves and tell you that
the real problem is a piggly wiggly down
the street do you really think that
they're looking out for you you really
think they care that you're struggling
to pay your uh pay your bills that
you're dealing with the highest
inflation in 40 years you really think
they care about that if you believe that
you probably believe that uh the unvaxed
are the reason for the surge let me give
you the list of uh some of the notable
people who've received money from pfizer
nancy pelosi jerry jerry nadler joe
manchin dick blumenthal liz cheney verm
buchanan dan crenshaw lindsey graham so
a lot of people by the way on the left
and on the right we're going to be doing
chat thursday here just so you know here
for mug club i would love it if you
smash that like button if you comment
but let me recap this for you because
this is important let's follow this
trail okay
you have
elected representatives who say worry
about kroger
worry about uh whatever it is any given
day worry about kroger worry about uh
fracking worry about taco tuesday
whatever the hell it is worry about
these things while simultaneously taking
your money
actually while simultaneously taking
your money while simultaneously
devaluing your money to prop up
businesses and companies who subsidize
their losses through you and privatize
all of their profits so these
politicians say here's money from the
taxpayer these companies then take that
money that they've gotten from the
taxpayer to lobby more politicians and
lawmakers so that they continue
to subsidize them at the cost of the
taxpayer do you have an idea how screwed
up that is you paid for the vaccine and
the vaccine line the pockets so pfizer
could go and get lindsey graham some
more money so that he could say hey
let's make sure that you subsidize more
vaccines i don't care if it's elizabeth
warren i don't care if it's jerry nadler
i don't care if it's mitch mcconnell
whoever it is all that needs to change
for this to stop is you don't need to
try socialism some new way you don't
need to fundamentally change the tax
code system what you just need to do is
say hey no one is too big to fail and by
the way no taxpayer dollars go to
private companies to prop them up you do
that guess what problem solved we're not
here and of course you have the choice
to put whatever you want in your own
body luck elizabeth warren's husband
pegging's his thing we'll see you later
piss off youtube
oh